i'm nate hodge the head chocolate maker
and co-founder of raqqa chocolate and
we're at our chocolate factory in red
hook brooklyn
[Music]
so the cacao pods are cut open and
there's a mixture of fruit surrounding
the seeds of the cocoa tree those are
scooped out and generally put into
sacks so they can be taken somewhere to
be fermented
this is a repurposed juicer
it has a custom casing and set of blades
for cracking the cocoa beans
we use them for separating the shell
from the nib like this just pure nibs
and what we want to do is start to
refine this so that we can turn it into
ooey gooey shiny rich chocolate these
are like indian spice grinders that are
used for chai
curries these have been repurposed for
cocoa we'll run it overnight and then
we'll add sugar in the morning
this is after it's gone through the
roller mill behind us this is gonna get
thicker and thicker and thicker and then
eventually you'll start to see like
sugar granules coming out and then the
machine will start grinding the solids
you want to re-coat all the particles in
fat and you want to reshape those
particles so since it's coming through
here in a really tight space it's
flattening the particles and that's
great we want small particles but what
we also want are particles that are
rounded into a pearl shape so that it
rolls off your palette instead of like
sticks to it they're gonna run this
through three times and by the end it's
just gonna be like a big knot of
chocolate
so after the chocolate has been massaged
and aerated
um then we're gonna do this which is the
process of tempering the chocolate so
it's aligning the polymorphic crystals
in the fats and the solids so that they
all harden at the same temperature
cocoa bean is roughly 50 cocoa powder 50
cocoa butter because we have 50
essentially a pure fat we like to play
with that fat hectares steeping
chanterelles in cocoa butter in the
holding tank we'll add a lot of the
other flavoring deep herbs or teas we
really want that like incredibly silky
texture and being able to flavor the
butter and then add that back in it
doesn't affect the texture
so then we'll uh roll the racks into
this box humidity and chocolate don't
mix so it goes in there at like a dry 55
degrees so the chocolate bars to set
perfectly rolled out stacked up over
here put into these white bins
and then this is our wrapping machine
we're doing like 1600 to 2000 bars a day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you